ça me
[Musique]
j'entends c'est une chanson qui est pas
tellement pas qu'un peu malheureuse mais
qui est plutôt qui parle de beaucoup de
frustration et d'angoise en fait c'est
une chanson qui parle de d'acouphènes
ça fait à peu près deux ans deux ans et
demi que j'en ai avant ça j'avais jamais
j'ai entendu beaucoup parler de ça parce
que mon père a pas mal de problèmes
d'oreille et j'avais conscience que ça
devait être terriblement stressant
angoissant et est assez terrible comme
comme sentiments et comme situation mais
je pensais pas que ça m'arriverait un
jour et puis un jour j'étais à une promo
télé et dans le stress je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé et c'est d'ailleurs
direct et en fait il y avait un problème
avec le micro qui avait pas de piles et
savez moi j'ai mis beaucoup plus fort
dans mon boîtier en pensant que c'était
un problème de ceux enfin bref j'ai reçu
un jus dans les oreilles et en fait je
me suis pas rendu compte mais j'ai pris
un gros coup quoi vraiment cessé
physique en fait puisque les leçons
c'est est fréquente et ça veut dire
qu'en fait elle vient de taper dans le
tympan et en fête le soir même j'ai eu
la merveilleuse idée de travailler un
nouveau son au casque pour pas déranger
les voisins
et quand j'ai arrêté la musique
j'aimerais encore le son dans les
oreilles je me souviens m'être levé
que tu fais dans l'appartement genre en
imaginant que c'était la fin du monde et
ça c'est pas qu'elle mène depuis et en
fait je me souviens sentiment d'énorme
angoisse parce que je savais que c'est
incurable et je savais qu'en fait on
peut rien y faire et que l'oreille c'est
vraiment hyper fragile parce que quand
elle est abîmée
c'est pour toujours en fait c'est très
lié au stress est très lié à au mental
et je sais que les premiers mois elle
était vraiment bizarre parce que j'en
parlais pas trop parce que je voulais
pas trop admettre que les avait un
problème
donc j'en ai parlé à personne au début
et comme je savais que mon frère avait
des acouphènes d'ailleurs elle avait
déjà écrit des chansons là dessus et
donc j'en ai même pas parlé à lui au
début parce que je voulais surtout pas
que je voulais pas admettre qu'elle est
le problème et comme mes oreilles c'est
vraiment un métier j'avais trop peur en
fait que ce soit un vrai problème
pendant longtemps j'ai rien fait à part
faire des recherches sur google en
pleine nuit en plein angoisse ce qui n'a
pas trop aidé et après j'ai été voir à
noël et puis un spécialiste puis un
autre et puis en fait bateaux s'ils
m'ont dit la même chose c'est bah oui il
ya un problème on le voit dans le schéma
que à telle fréquence tu l'entends pas à
donner à comprendre ft est en fait
tellement je me suis dit ok bon bah ce
sont que j'entends je vais l'entendre
toute ma vie et ça va m'accompagner
je me suis dit c'est que ça devait
arriver et en fait j'ai réussi à
beaucoup par l'accepter
donc je me suis dis pas écrire cette
chanson ça m'aidait à moi peut sortir un
sur deux grosses grosses angoisses ou ça
vraiment constitué six mois de ma vie où
je sais d un groupe d angoisse que j'en
ai pas bien que j'avais vraiment
l'impression de devoir faire le deuil du
silence parce que je l'entendais plus le
silence et en même temps je me suis dit
c'est que c'est une manière de d'un peu
sensibilisé les gens parce que même à
mes propres concerts même si on fait
quand même vachement attention bafa fort
quoi balla annonce il dirait de parler
que je bois je l'entends j'attendrai
brottes
ben en fait il ya dépend en fait dans
les deux oreilles il ya une sorte de
bruit blanc qui fait comme je sais pas
si tu serres et d'un très fort tentant
une sorte de petit bruit très aigu
derrière les oreilles comme ça deux
jeunes a expliqué moi j'entends ça dans
mes deux oreilles
constamment et ça si je me suis vraiment
habitué ça c'était au début c'était plus
dur c'était vraiment un bruit qui je
visualise est en fait je vous le voyez
mesure de brouillard dans mes oreilles
et c'est vraiment un bruit c'est
pourtant en face qu'il faut savoir c'est
que si tu travailles avec nous c'était
entendu sont trop forts pour tes
oreilles pendant plus de 30 minutes
ça peut te ça peu de blessés pour toute
ta vie moi tout ça c'est la forme
vraiment un truc que je me suis dit mais
c'est à croire que j'en ai aussi peu
entendu parler
malgré que mon père mon nez parler quand
même et des aliments et parler mais
quand généralement on n'en parle pas
trop comment un vrai danger alors que
franchement les acouphènes
je pense que c'est dans les trucs qui
peuvent rendre fou quoi moi j'ai de la
chance parce que c'est encore vraiment
très léger mais je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui peuvent pas être donné dans des
pièces comme ça je pense qu'à des jeux
qui font des dépressions et tout est et
je leur envoie tout mon soutient
d'ailleurs parce que vraiment moi ma
mamma ma plus grande peur c'est de ça
s'empire en fait